[Music]
welcome to the random fish we hope you
have a continuously lovely evening here
is our menu what do you recommend each
of our dishes has its own special flavor
and story our most popular fish is the
normal fish but if you'd like something
more exotic you can try the Koshi fish
it has an amazingly thick juicy tail or
the expo fish it will make your hunger
decay exponentially and now for
tonight's entertainment this is our star
Randy
she loves swimming all around her tank
randomly your challenge if you choose to
accept it is to predict her horizontal
position in the tank and answer
questions about Randy's probabilities
Randy and her tank are 2-dimensional the
area of the water is one each time Randy
pauses her position is uniformly random
in the tank this means the probability
of her being in a particular region is
the area of that region for example the
probability that Randy is in this
triangle is half the probability that
she is in this square whose area is
double the triangles area and the
probability of being in the square is
the same as the probability of being in
this blob with the same area ok everyone
what's the probability that Randy is at
x equals 1.5 we are looking at our
horizontal position in the tank based on
where her eye is that's easy I'll just
measure the height of the tank and x
equals 1.5 okay point three three know
the probability is zero
wait that's crazy doesn't that mean we
would never see Randy at one point five
look she's there right now Randy is
approximately at one point five but do
you really think it's exact one point
five zero zero zero zero forever well
she's at one point five as far as we can
tell
even with the best ruler in the world
there's a limit to how precise our
measurements can be
so when you say the probability of being
at 1.5 is 0.33 do you mean the
probability of being at one point five
zero one point five zero zero or what
I don't know Brandis position is a
continuous random variable even if we
can't measure it to infinite precision
the probability is zero that her
position is one point five zero zero
zero zero forever I know that's what's
taught in continued appleís but it
doesn't seem very practical just to say
the probability is zero Oh
can we talk about something other than
fish I'm just not sure we're compatible
I admire how you handle challenges so
straightforwardly and with such
discretion but we live in such different
spaces Norma I love you I know I'm not
the smoothest guy in the world but we
actually have a lot in common and
together combining discrete and
continuous perspectives we can achieve
so much more than we could separately I
love you too we do speak the same
language at least the language of
randomness and uncertainty let's
continue trying to understand each other
then okay I agree that Rainey's position
is continuous not discrete she's a fish
swimming in the water not a frog jumping
from one lily pad to another but then
how can the probability of being at 1.5
be 0 doesn't that mean it's impossible
for ready to be at 1.5 but to get from
the left half of the tank to the right
half of the tank she must pass through
1.5 good point to swim from x equals 1
to x equals 2 Randi must cross through
every real number from 1 to 2 ancient
stat land philosophers were puzzled
about how that could be possible
how can Randi pass by infinitely many
intermediate points in a finite amount
of time anyway if we observe Randi over
a long time interval it is very likely
that Randi will visit x equals 1 point 5
at least once but here we are checking
on Randi at one time point so the
probability is 0 that Randi is exactly
at 1 point 5 at that one time point but
as a practical matter what's the
probability that Randi is close to 1
point 5
well then we should specify an error
tolerance how close is close if say we
want Randi to be within point O 5 of 1.5
we can look at the probability that she
is between 1 point 4 5
and 1.55 and how would you compute that
just find the area under the curve from
one point four five to one point five
five the curve formed by the tank is a
probability density function also known
as a PDF not to be confused with
Portable Document format a PDF is a
non-negative function such that the area
under the curve is one for a continuous
random variable X the probability that X
is in a particular interval is the area
under the PDF curve over that interval
note that the PDF of Randy's horizontal
position is the curve formed by the tank
since the probability of her being in a
region is the area of that region well
that's great now time for a new question
what's the probability that Randy is
between x equals 1 and x equals 2 same
idea we just need the area under the
curve from x equals 1 to x equals 2
seems messy to compute though but wait
there's a sweet symmetry here Randy is
equally likely to be in the interval 0
to 1 1 to 2 and 2 to 3 so by symmetry
the probability is 1/3 of being between
1 & 2 you're right that's beautiful
I didn't realize that breaking the
problem up into discrete chunks would
help so much well done everyone now
what's the probability that Randy is
between 1.5 and - we need the area under
the curve from 1.5 to 2 we can't invoke
symmetry here so finding this area
requires calculus as an approximation
though how about making a grid in the
tank and using a discrete random
variable good idea that's like how we
can approximate the area of a region by
adding up the areas of lots of narrow
rectangles point 1 for our final round
for the evening will be a face-off
between the two tables that have done
the best so far Norma and Bernie and
gamma and Gumbel instead of having a
probability for Randy let's up the ante
and give a prediction where do you think
she is
the table with the answer that's closer
to the truth will win a free trip to the
stud land games in average Mont what if
there's a time well that may be common
where you come from but here in continue
Appa lists we don't worry about ties the
probability is zero that two independent
continuous random variables will be
equal but I'm not sure the guesses will
be specified to infinite precision and
two tables could follow the same
strategy and arrive at exactly the same
guess well in that unlikely event I will
choose the winner randomly okay so half
the time Randy's to the left of one
point four two and half the time choose
to the right of one point four two so
how about guessing one point four two
that's the median but here is the mean
the center of mass so how about guessing
one point four six how can we decide
which form of average to use for our
prediction the mean or the median last
time I visited average Mont I learned
that if we are predicting a quantity X
and want to minimize the expected
absolute difference between X and our
prediction we should guess the median
but if we want to minimize the expected
squared difference between X and our
prediction we should guess the mean but
the closest guess in terms of absolute
difference will also be the closest
guess in terms of squared difference so
it's still not clear whether we should
choose the mean or the median aha let's
keep in mind that we are trying to do
better than the other table not trying
to optimize some measure of long-run
performance if we play this game many
times if we guess the median and the
other table guesses a different value
see we have more than a 50% chance that
our guests will be closer if C is
greater than the median we win for all
the cases to the left of the median plus
everything up to half way between the
guesses similarly if C is less than the
median we win for all cases to the right
of the median plus everything up to
halfway between
beautiful so let's guess the median one
point for two
there's Randi at 1.37 Norma and Bernie
guest 1.42 while gamma and Gumbel guests
1.46 congratulations Norma and Bernie
your outstanding thinking about averages
has earned you a free trip to the stop
learn games in average Mont Ernie and
Norma have realized that discrete and
continuous thinking are complementary
each can give useful approximations and
insights for the other together discrete
and continuous approaches form a
powerful framework for modeling the
world
[Music]
you